نعم زين العابدين دعنا نبدا مع هذا الخبر
العاجل الذي يتحدث عن اصابه اسرائيلي
بجروح لم يحدد ماهيه هذه الاصابه جراء
اطلاق صاروخ مضاد للدروع نحو موقع عسكري
اسرائيلي في مزارع شبعه المحتله نحن نعلم
انه تم استهداف هذه المنطقه منذ صباح
اليوم بعده صواريخ اطلقت من الاراضي
اللبنانيه
والان صحيفه هارتس تعلن عن وجود اصابه
ولكن يتم تحديد ما هي هذه الاصابه هل هي
اصابه متوسطه ام اصابه حرجه وما اذا كانت
هذه الاصابه في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي ام
في صفوف المدنيين ولكن على الارجح انها في
صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي لنوعيه استهداف هذه
المواقع نتحدث عن مواقع عسكريه في تلك
المنطقه في مزارع شبعه وبالتالي هذا ايضا
يضاف الى سلسله العمليات التي تم شنها من
قبل حزب الله باتجاه البلدات الحدوديه
الاسرائيليه صباح هذا اليوم سقط صاروخ
مضاد للدروع اخر في وسط مدينه كريات شموني
في شارع حيوي جدا ووفق التحقيقات الاوليه
الميدانيه كان هذا الصاروخ من المفترض ان
يستهدف نقطه عسكريه لتجمع الجنود في تلك
المنطقه البلدات الحدوديه الاسرائيليه
تحولت الى مناطق عسكريه مغلقه منذ بدء هذه
المواجهه وايضا تم اجلاء جميع ساكنيها من
تلك المنطقه وتحويلهم الى الفنادق نتحدث
عن اكثر من 70,000 اسرائيلي تم نقلهم من
هذه المناطق الحدوديه في الجليل الاعلى
والجليل الغربي منعا لمسهم في هذه
الصواريخ وعمليات حزب الله المتتاليه
الجيش الاسرائيلي بدوره يقول انه استهدف
مصادر اطلاق هذه الصواريخ في الاراضي
اللبنانيه دون ان يحدد اي مواقع تم
استهدافه وقال انه استهدف مواقع عسكريه
تابعه لحزب الله عن طريق ارسال المسيرات
وعبر الغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه وايضا
عبر القصف المدفعي يعني قبل ساعه من الان
سمعنا اصوات اي جدا عنيفه جراء الانفجارات
الناجمه عن المدفعيه الاسرائيليه التي
استهدفت اطراف البلدات الحدوديه لبنانيه
شكرا لك